welcome back to Tipping Point I'm your
host Cara McKinney Joe Biden hosted a
reception at the White House on Monday
to celebrate the Muslim holiday of I I'd
al-fatir after sending out a tweet that
basically acted like Islam Built This
Nation the holiday marks the end of the
fast of Ramadan something he compared to
the fasting the Catholics engaged in
during Lent in the words of our next
guest Biden's speech was something of a
cringe Fest and highlights the dynamic
in which Biden and his allies in the
Democrat poverty reduce identity groups
to their most basic form and then Pander
to them in reality Biden's policies are
creating chaos for Americans of all
Stripes including immigrants and to that
point the by Administration is yet to
properly vet more than 88 000 Afghan
refugees who were brought to the U.S
following our withdrawal from
Afghanistan in August of 2021. four
Republican congressmen sent a letter to
Secretary of Homeland Security Alejandro
mayorcas explained that DHS experienced
obstacles to fully inspecting and
screening thousands of refugees posing a
possible risk to National Security you
don't say Customs and Border patrols
also enable to do a proper screening on
a vacuoes because they lack the data
necessary to do so this inquiry is a
part of the House GOP investigation into
our withdrawal and two of the house reps
you signed the letter previously called
for the Biden Administration to turn
over all documents pertaining to our
exit from Kabul which left 13 U.S
service members dead in an Isis terror
attack scores of Afghans were also
killed in an effort that was widely seen
as being poorly planned and poorly
executed if the by Administration
doesn't comply with the request then
House Republicans could theoretically
subpoena Biden in a similar manner to
how Secretary of State Anthony blinken
was subpoenaed in March for failing to
disclose classified documents confirming
that American officials knew that the
Taliban would likely take power when we
left Afghanistan join us out to discuss
all the samura's Robert Spence or the
director of jihad watch Robert thanks
for being here tonight always good to
talk to you Kara thank you great so all
this time later and they still haven't
gotten around to vetting what's going on
well probably this is all part of the
plan I don't think these people are
stupid I think they're evil and so we
know from Alejandro Mallorca several
years ago at the time the Kabul fell
that most of the people that the Biden
Administration was bringing over were
not holders of the special immigrant
visas now the special immigrant visas
were given to people who helped the
troops in Afghanistan now if we didn't
give the visas to people who helped us
who did we give them to that was never
answered never explained and then
they've had all this time to vet these
people since they've been here and
nothing has been done you gotta think
that they're either the most incompetent
fools who have ever walked the planet or
else this is what they want they want to
sow chaos and dissolution and trouble
and crime among American citizens
because it's all part of their larger
socialist internationalist plans to
undermine the nation-state itself now
this I would have said this was crazy
just a few years ago but what other
explanation is there for not vetting
these people after all this time
and also I know maybe it's glib to say
but when CBP says well we didn't have
the data for you know for our agency to
kind of help with any vetting whatsoever
through the DHS I was thinking well yeah
because we left a lot of those
Biometrics and other data with the
Taliban and the Taliban was using that
to hunt down any of our friends and
allies left behind so maybe that's where
it went and I you know again I hate to
be good because lives were at stake but
it really is as he said it's really so
terrible to recount do you think the DHS
secretary mayorkas is going to really
respond to this letter or work with
Congress I mean his track record would
show probably not
that's right I don't have any hope that
he's going to suddenly come clean and
start to reveal what's going on here and
the fact is that he knows that he's got
people behind him he knows that the
Department of Justice is under the
control of Merrick Garland who is part
of the same corrupt regime that the FBI
is under the control of Christopher Ray
same thing so who's going to hold him
accountable this is what they want this
is what they got either like I say
either they're stupid or they're evil
but they're all in it together one way
or the other and so they're going to
protect each other and my orcas will
face no accountability whatsoever
and then it's also kind of interesting
uh just of the last few days on Twitter
I saw a lot of people kind of you know
talking about this tweet it either came
from Biden's account or from the White
House's official account from one of
these accounts and it was basically
saying that Islam built this nation and
it and that was kind of the idea it gave
up it didn't necessarily say it in those
words it was just kind of funny people
were using it to kind of poke fun saying
well I seem to remember the Barb re Wars
as one of the first Wars the U.S had to
get into after the American Revolution
because our our men were being taken
hostage Sailors were being taken hostage
by the Muslim Barbary Pirates and when
Thomas Jefferson tried to ask why saying
hey why are you guys taking our men they
went well because you guys are Christian
and we're Muslim and you know that's
that we get to take what we want from
you so that's kind of interesting you
have a whole article over at PJ media
explaining you know Biden as he said his
cringe Fest over at the White House
that's wonder if you could kind of
outline some of the highlights or I
guess low lights from that event
well Cara the first thing is indeed that
he said that Muslims have been part of
the United States ever since its
founding and that's something that's a
myth that goes back to the Obama
Administration which first started
having dinners for edel fitter and other
Muslim holidays uh at the White House
and Obama several times said that there
were Americans involved in the founding
and nobody ever said well wait a minute
who were they where were they where were
the Muslim founding fathers who were the
Muslim signers of the Declaration of
Independence and after Biden's reception
for Eid I saw that several news outlets
were saying that there were three or
four Muslims who were fighting in the
revolution but they don't even actually
know that these people were Muslims they
know that they were black Africans who
were probably slaves and they were
probably not Muslims at all but had
Islamic names and had converted to
Christianity one so they were here
because there is no record of uh slaves
in large numbers practicing Islam so
that's it's not even clear that these
people were Muslims at all you're
talking about a handful of people who
may have been forced to fight and this
is the great Muslim contribution to the
American Revolution it's clearly
historical revisionism designed to
Pander to a voting group that they want
to keep safely on their side nowadays
but there's absolutely nothing to it you
don't hear about Muslims in the United
States at all until the late 19th
century and only really in the last few
decades do you see them as a significant
political force here and it would be one
thing to do this kind of you know
reaching out if we didn't also forget
who we were as a people ourselves but of
course we lost that a long time ago you
know even with the the trans shooter in
Tennessee specifically targeting I know
they're hiding the manifesto once again
after saying no we'll release it this
time oh just kidding not anymore but
killing Christians and you know buying
with everything else will say I stand
with XYZ Community whenever any even if
it's a stretch of any Community being
quote unquote affected well this isn't a
stretch people were literally killed and
no I stand with the Christian Community
or icing with you you don't see that and
that is really really disappointing but
before I let you go tonight some funny
points it seems uh Biden he told someone
in the crowd to to hush up boy and also
having the quote here wish everyone a
Happy Eid Mubarak I was wondering if you
could explain some of that before I let
you go yeah Ramadan Mubarak or Eid
Mubarak rather is what Muslims say to
each other on edel fitter to to sell
it's like saying Merry Christmas it's
saying have a blessed feast and so when
Biden said happy Eid Mubarak it's like
saying happy Merry Christmas it's it's
it doesn't make any sense and it just
shows that the man doesn't have any idea
what he's really talking about he's just
doing what his handlers tell him and
pandering to the groups that they tell
him to Pander to the story as old as
time unfortunately Robert thanks for
dropping by tonight
you